we're told that parallelogram ABCD has
the following vertices and they give us
the coordinates of the different
vertices and they say is parallelogram
ABCD a rectangle and Y so pause this
video and try to think about this on
your own before we work through it
together all right now let's work
through it together so in general if you
know that something is already a
parallelogram and you wanted to
determine whether it's a rectangle it's
really a question of whether the
adjacent size intersect at a right angle
so for example a parallelogram might
look something like this what we know
about a parallelogram is that the
opposite sides are parallel so this side
is parallel to that side and that this
side is parallel to this side and all
rectangles are parallelograms but not
all parallelograms are rectangles in
order for a parallelogram to be a
rectangle these sides need to intersect
at right angles and clear the way I drew
this one it doesn't look like that but
let's see if we can figure that out
based on the coordinates that they have
given us and to help us visualize let me
just put some coordinates let me draw
some axes here so that's my x-axis and
then this is my y-axis let's see the
coordinates let's see we have twos four
sixes so let me actually count by and
eights let me count by twos here so we
have two four six and eight and then we
have negative two negative four negative
six negative eight we have two four six
and eight and then we'd have negative
two negative four negative six and
negative eight so each hash mark is
another two I'm counting by twos here
and so let's plot these points and I'll
do it in different colors so we can keep
track so a is negative 6 comma negative
four so negative two negative four
negative six and then negative four we'd
go right over here that is point a then
we have point B which is negative two
comma six so negative two comma six so
that's going to go up to four
and six so that is point B right over
there and then we have point C which is
at 8 , 2 so 8 comma 2 right over there
that is point C and then last but not
least we have point D which is at 4
comma negative 8 4 comma negative 8
right over there Point D and so our
quadrilateral or we actually know it's a
parallelogram looks like this so you
have segment a B like that you have
segment BC
and that looks like that segment CD
looks like this and segment ad looks
like this and we know already that it's
a parallelogram so we know that segment
a B is parallel to segment DC and
segment BC is parallel to segment ad but
what we really need to do is figure out
whether they are intersecting at right
angles and to do that using the
coordinates to figure that out we have
to figure out the slopes of these
different line segments and so let's
figure out first the slope of a B so the
slope of segment a B is going to be
equal to our change in Y over change in
X so our change in Y is going to be 6
minus negative 4 6 minus negative 4 over
negative 2 minus negative 6 negative 2
minus negative 6 and so this is going to
be equal to 6 plus 4 which is 10 over
negative 2 minus negative 6 that's the
thing is the same thing as negative 2
plus 6 so that's going to be over 4
which is the same thing as 5 halves
all right that's interesting what is the
slope of a segment BC the slope of
segment BC is going to be equal to once
again change in Y over change in X our Y
coordinates change in Y is 2 minus 6 2
minus 6 over 8 minus a negative 2 8
minus negative 2 which is equal to
negative 4 over
and then eight minus negative two is the
same thing as eight plus two over 10
which is the same thing as negative
two-fifths now in other videos in your
algebra class you might have learned
that the slopes of lines that intersect
at right angles or the slopes of lines
that form a right angle at their point
of intersection that they are going to
be the opposite reciprocals and you can
actually see that right over here these
are opposite reciprocals if you take the
reciprocal of this top slope you would
get two fists and then you take the
opposite of it or in this case the
negative of it you are going to get
negative two-fifths so these are
actually these are perpendicular lines
so this lets us know that a B and is
perpendicular segment a B is
perpendicular to segment BC so we know
that this is the case and we could keep
onto doing that but in a parallelogram
if one if one set of segments intersect
at a right angle all of them are going
to intersect at a right angle and we
could show that more rigorously in other
places but this is enough evidence for
me to know that this is indeed going to
be a rectangle if you want you could
continue to do this analysis and you
will see that these this is
perpendicular this is perpendicular and
that is perpendicular as well but let's
see which of these choices match up to
what we just did used so choice a says
yes and yes would be they it is a
rectangle because a B is equal so the
length of segment a B is equal to the
length of segment a D and the length of
segment BC is equal to the length of
segment C D so that might be true
I haven't validated it but just because
this is true and because we do know that
ABCD is a parallelogram that wouldn't it
let me know that we are actually dealing
with a rectangle for example you can
have a parallelogram where even all the
sides are congruent so you could have a
parallelogram that looks like this and
obviously if all of the sides are
congruent you're dealing with a rhombus
but a rhombus is still not necessarily
going to be a rectangle and so I would
rule this top one out this check in so
second choice says yes and it says
because BC is perpendicular to a B
we saw that by seeing that their slopes
are the opposite reciprocals of each
other and of course we know that ABCD is
a parallelogram so I am liking this
choice and these other ones say that
claim that this is not a rectangle but
we already deduced that it is a
rectangle so we could rule these out as
well